[Music]
where's that kid
[Music]
mission for what we accidentally built
the lunar module
a little too small how'd that happen
listen are you good at math yeah do you
get a perfect 100 on every test no okay
we need a kid like you to test this
accidentally smaller version on the
lunar surface and soon stan you're our
only
hope okay
great
let's forget about all this for now
we'll come back to this part later
first let me tell you about life back
then living in the houston area in the
late 60s it was a great time and place
to be a kid
but the world was changing and so is how
we saw ourselves in it right on
mom is that one a hippie yeah yeah
that's a hippie how about that one no
his hair is not long enough but he's
wearing bell bottoms okay that's a
hippie
i think i like hippies
[Music]
this is a covert operation that means it
does not exist no one can know about
this not your parents not your brothers
not your sisters no one
[Music]
60 seconds and counting ignition
sequence stars
stand are you ready
ready
apollo 10 and a half this is houston do
you read
[Music]
houston
[Music]
[Music]
you